all right now it's time to chat with our
special guests a wow the women of
wrestling stars tessa blanchard and the
beast and they are joined by the boss
lady who runs it all the best owner in
all of sports and one of my come on now
on this planet the one
um the women of wrestling will air next
year on cbs and sinclair stations genie
got to know right off the bat who's
harder to manage nba players or women
wrestlers oh i already
i you know this this is such a passion
project for me the women i believe in
them we have two strong competitors here
this is a platform for them to shine the
nba's had that for a long time it's time
for the women to get that chance that's
her not wanting to say those fellows are
divas those basketball players are just
these ladies are so much easier i know
right
against the rolls beast
one two
you are the current world champion thus
the belt everybody that's right yeah uh
you beat tessa
do you remind me oh boy things got real
real personal i mean since you're gonna
bring it up i mean let's talk about it
as you can see i mean let's talk about
it
title's on my shoulder which means
someone
got the beat down they deserved yeah we
now know who's the biggest
who's the baddest
it's the beast no worries oh um the beat
down that you deserve tessa i i right i
mean i gotta let you respond to that one
how are you gonna get this belt back
she knows what's up the minute that we
step in the ring beast you know
you know
who the biggest who the baddest is
you call yourself that but every single
time that we've been in the ring
i haven't gotten just beat down
i was gonna say i was gonna say i'm
gonna stand over here y'all everybody
okay
um you both thought about hashing out
your differences
like maybe over coffee or something or
no it's just you will get back in the
ring again
oh definitely oh i'm getting that back
you can try tessa's eyes got real
[ __ ]
don't play with me kevin fraser i think
she's about to jump over here and get
you i do want to say we saw the beast at
dinner last night and after dinner she
went and worked out she got up this
morning and worked out that's a beast
that's a beast that's the beast
genie lord knows you did not need
another job
i mean for real you do just about
everything so why did you want to invest
and really start this women of wrestling
because there's so many female athletes
that don't get a chance to shine
and
people in a position like mine have to
invest in opportunities for women to
compete and to shine and to show us what
they got and and these two women right
here deserve to the spotlight they
deserve to be seen you know this is a
passion project and i'm so happy with
our partnership with viacom cbs it's a
dream come true i'm a born legend if
people get in my way i steamroll through
them
[Music]
now i know this is something ladies that
you both can agree on i want you both to
talk about how far women's wrestling has
come and and then also you know i know
you there's still a way to go but in the
last few decades how far have you guys
come
who's going to start looking
did you see them look at each other they
just looked at each other like i wish
you would talk first i wish you would
well in in
my own experiences professional
wrestling has been my life since before
i was born my father my grandfather and
with that i
i followed my passion it's taken me all
over the world i've gotten to live in
different countries win championship
titles all over the world
but now with wow this is without a doubt
the biggest platform for women's
wrestling in history
in history and to be a part of it
it's a testament that we're changing the
status quo for women's wrestling for
professional wrestling all together and
it's just such a blessing to be a part
of it
for once i'll agree with tessa
i knew this was something we could get
them to agree on genie
but here's the thing for myself like
underneath all this i'm i'm muscles i'm
tattoos i don't look like you're normal
you're standard female
so wow gives me an opportunity to be who
i am unapologetically we have women from
all walks of life from corporate to blue
collar and and we all get a chance to be
who we are and shine the way we are and
be strong in any way we want to be that
made my heart smile i am serious that
made my heart smile that is so amazing
and you know what those wrestling fans
wrestling fans are unlike any fans
jeannie are you ready for that the
passion that wrestling fans bring and
how are you tapping into it well uh
the wow fans are amazing they've
supported us and you know i'm just i'm
waiting to see the the next superstar
like dwayne the rock johnson like you
know um
you know go on to to to bigger and
greater things like film and television
and just see it the rock john cena now
the biz
like doing so yeah i mean it's time for
a woman to have that breakthrough right
and go to that next level and i think
y'all can do it hey genie you just had a
milestone birthday and you used that to
announce that you are in love and um you
have a you have a new guy and i'm so
happy for you you and jay moore are
dating yes yes jay moore is um somebody
that captured my heart and i i couldn't
be happier and i just had to share it
with the world
[Music]